[Musica]
[Risate]
ora da soli
ora so perché mi sono laureato in
ingegneria nucleare
ora so perché ho aspettato sei mesi in
più solo per la soddisfazione che la mia
tesi fosse a bordo del carico
scientifico dello space shuttle
discovery che voi avete appena visto
decollo la regione è che sono messi
fatto tutto questo quarant'anni fa oggi
forse non sarei qui a parlare un evento
che si intitola canta dunque bene che la
massa la pena
io però oggi sono qui a parlarvi di un
campo molto particolare cioè il
countdown che riguarda la mobilità
elettrica
il caldaro in realtà non sono pochi
secondi che avete visto in questo
filmato il countdown al processo molto
più molto più lungo dura mesi mesi prima
della missione per fare tutti i sistemi
preparando esperimenti prepari
dispositivi di misura fino ad arrivare a
quei pochi secondi avrete notato che
attivino 5 secondi si accende il motore
principale e lì ci sono ancora cinque
secondi in quella che se le può essere
abortita si può ancora fermarla dopo 5
secondi partono i motori laterali a quel
punto bisogna andare non c'è il taffetà
bisogna sperare che tutta la
preparazione del caudano dia i suoi
frutti
dobbiamo decollare abbiamo arriva dal
boss era dobbiamo remare un'atmosfera
dobbiamo arrivare a destinazione dove
finalmente eseguiremo
che è l'oggetto della nostra spedizione
allora nella nostra metà fra il
countdown è un oggetto lungo e anche
alla trasformazione alla mobilità
elettrica è un oggetto lungo in italia
circolano 36 milioni di vetture se
avvengono 2 milioni all'anno anche se
domani proibisse mo la vendita dei
veicoli tecnici ci metteremo almeno 18
anni
ovviamente ci metteremo molti di più in
realtà c'è un'altra ragione per cui
questo processo è così lento ed è questa
il settore della automobile vale nel suo
complesso circa 150 miliardi di euro
adorano solidale sono divisi come vedete
nella slide to tel
non tutti sanno forse che in italia si
spende più per comprare il carburante di
fatto si estende per comprare le
automobili che ogni anno
se noi e adesso io potessi schioccare le
dita e magicamente trasformare i 36
milioni di vetture che ci sono fuori
comprese le vostre in elettori
i numeri cambierebbero lo vedete lì
sotto non tanto sul prezzo di acquisto
che più o meno rimarrebbe uguale mappe
rese di 53 miliardi per il carburante
diventerebbero 24 miliardi
potete vedere gli altri dettagli ma
insomma il totale e che mancherebbero
all'appello basso modo 50 miliardi di
euro all'anno
ma non è soltanto fatto che mancano
questi soldi cambiano anche i soggetti i
53 miliardi di benzina
noi compriamo dalla scelta da principe
trova i 24 miliardi di energia elettrica
li compriamo dall'enel dall'era dall
unicità lizzate perciò è un per
trasformazione gigantesca che batteranno
struttura vissuto economico in maniera
mai vista prima
per arrivavano impatto paragonabile a
quello che avrà la mobilità elettrica
bisogna ritornare indietro
il motore vapore nell'ottocento una
domanda che forse li sentite leggete
stesso sui giornali in chiave ma se
tutte le automobili diventassero
elettriche la rete ce la farà a
sopportare avremmo abbastanza energia
elettrica benissimo
guardate questo grazie fotografiche sono
i dati storici del consumer e 30 in
italia
vedete la prima parte della curva in
crescita più o meno costante dagli anni
80 infine arrivare un maxi mito nel 2005
2006 di circa 340 terra l'attore di
consumo di emergere regata né i consumi
sono andati calando li vedete
rappresentati dalla linea tratteggiata
perché sono andati calando ma perché a
forza di installare i doppi vetri di
cambiare le lampadine
di contrarre elettrodomestici in classe
a a a
i nostri consumi sono calati i nostri
consumi sono calati
ora se questa curva discendente noi
sovrapponiamo quella relativa alla
mobilità elettrica
vedete bene che non ritorneremo mai più
a consumare 340 terawattora di energia
elettrica non possiamo stare tranquilli
l'energia certi ci sarà anche in futuro
ma io sono qui a parlare oggi
l'infrastruttura infrastrutture la parte
è una parte importante
la militante perché non si comprano le
auto elettriche perchè non ci sono i
caricatori e vedi il rifornimento e
riferire quali siamo abituati a fare non
si fa in un modo solo ci si ferma un
distributore si riempie di serie pen
serbatoio questo servizio è garantito da
circa 22 mila distributori di su sparsi
sul territorio nazionale che tutti
insieme fanno circa 80.000 pompe è un
modo semplice la mobilità elettrica è
leggermente ri complicato perché ci sono
due tipi di rifornimenti cerri movimento
che si fa di notte a casa propria con
caricatore di un certo tipo che usano
certa tecnologia e c'è il rifornimento
che si fa di giorno con un altro tipo di
caricatore con un'altra tecnologia da un
punto di vista veramente economico tutto
con la differenza è che il caricatore
tipo costa diciamo 2.000 euro anche di
meno il caricatore del secondo tipo di
costa 35 40mila purtroppo c'è una grande
differenza
quanti ne servono del tipo di problema
potete andare a quell'indirizzo vedendo
di tutti i calcoli ma prendete il
risultato buono ce ne vogliono circa 125
mila un numero che non è poi distante
dagli 80 metri da via 80.000 pompe che
oggi abbiamo per fare rifornimento
e quanto costa tutto bene se c'è un
problema che la mobilità elettrica non è
quello dei soldi
ricordate alla slide in prima serata che
fatta attenzione dopo di interno siamo
passati da 53 miliardi armando di
benzina 24 miliardi all'anno di energia
elettrica la differenza fa liam
risveglio 19 miliardi tutta
l'infrastruttura di cui vi ho parlato
adesso costa meno di 5 miliardi con il
risparmio di un anno ci paghiamo quattro
volte l'infrastruttura che ci serve
non è un problema di sorte attività un
problema di sincronia perché finché io
non è stato i caricatori in voi non vi
finalmente le capacità e voi non vi
contratta la macchina elettrica
i miei caricatori non renderlo nulla e
allora cosa facciamo chi è che parte per
primo ma per ciò limita un problema di
questo genere per illustrare lo stesso
concetto con un'altra un'altra napoli ha
immagino che nella foto non faccia
alzare le mani tanto non le vedrai per
come dire perfettamente in inter ma
immagino uno magari abbia fatto lo scavo
la stagione si ricorda il momento di
montare la testa non è difficile notare
una tenda canadese
se però noi montano 10 tende canadesi
con il criterio della produzione in
serie in stile fordista cercheremo di
rizzare prima tutti i pali perché
abbiamo tutti i soldi che abbiamo tutti
i tempi i pannelli di napoli con i temi
scopriamo nei panni sono caduti
allora il lupetto che rende tutto scemo
sa benissimo che per montare la tenda ci
vuole un lupetto e dei pali e un
gruppetto che metterete a una formalità
fra il tema è quello di trovare il modo
di farsi di mettere i caricatori là dove
servono
nel mondo
qui servono in modo che i caricatori e
l'utilizzo vadano di pari passo
facciamo un esempio immaginiamo un
azienda che ha tre sedi e vedere qui a
dieci e siccome un'azienda molto
sensibile all'ambiente e ha potuto
opporre questa terna decide di dotarsi
di veicoli elettrici allora compratore
ma credete che si installa i caricatori
nelle proprie sedi prime e l'autonomia
dell'auto nette che la vedete le cerchio
azzurro non è sufficiente l'automobile
parte da ma non riesce ad avere al
richiamo che questa convinzione il
progetto non può partire perché il
rischio di rilasciare il mag i datori a
secco è appunto gratta come può
funzionare questo progetto può
funzionare se qualcuno in posizione
strategica persone
all'origine in particolare una persona
importanza installa caricato dei
caricatori in modo che con una breve
sosta il mio guidatore si ferma fa
rifornimento può ripartire dalla
prestazione chiaro però che se i
caricatori del primo tipo ci possono
mettere tutta la notte carica d'apertura
i caricatori del secondo tipo devono
essere veloci perché io posso fare una
persona per mangiare un panino e fumare
una sigaretta non posso far fermare per
quattro ore e mezza in attesa da un auto
si carichino è chiaro va man mano che
questi caricatori erano distribuiti sul
territorio e che io offro creato
l'infrastruttura che poi potrà servire
ciascuno di noi per prendere la
decisione di passare alla mobilità
elettrica è ovvio che siccome ci stiamo
rivolgendo alla di 13 aziende
trasformazione non sono poi così
semplice richiedono una pianificazione
accurata me piace molto il modello di
questo studioso americano che si incappa
crosta che vi ripropongo il quale dice
che sostanzialmente per un processo di
trasformazione complesso come questo
sono necessarie quelli cinque componenti
che vedete raffigurate nei versi coloni
se le mani una o più di queste il
risultato non è che è successo ma in
forma diversa di fallimento
ancora una volta applicato al nostro
discorso quelle cinque scatoline
colorate vogliono dire altrettante
risposte a queste domande la prima delle
quali forse la più importante perché
perché l'azienda sta facendo quello che
sta facendo
qual è non restivo che voleva come
funziona la mobilità elettrica tutte le
altre domande
le potete vedere per cui diciamo che il
processo è abbastanza chiaro ma va
affrontato con un criterio che sia
diciamo così organizzativo più che non è
motivo allora per riassumere perché non
mi concentro sulla fede perché le
aziende sono quelli lenti dopo tengo
massimo del beneficio col minimo dello
sforzo le aziende in italia sono
proprietarie di circa 6 per cento di
quei 36 milioni di vetture bi circolo ma
questi 36 milioni di questi questo 6 per
cento percorre quasi mo di 18 per cento
di chilometri la più inquinante delle
ferrari che percorre i 500 km all'anno
purtroppo inquina molto di meno della
più pulita delle panda che ne fa 40.000
perciò devo ragionare in termini di
chilometri e le aziende sono
responsabili di una parte elevata di
questi chilometri
il secondo non certo è che di questa
infrastruttura andrà costruita per gradi
l'italia al vanto di essere stato tra i
primi paesi a mano anzi il primo paese
al mondo a costruire le ferrovie la
famosa napoli portici nel 1839 come
vedere però le ferrovie la copertura
delle ferrovie è andata via via man
aumentandone che abbiamo aspettato a
1.905 percorsa nei dei biglietti sono a
napoli pollici
man mano che facciamo un pezzo di
ferrovia lo ha prima ma pubblico così in
parte entravamo dell'investimento allora
tutte le infrastrutture si costruiscono
per gradi
l'alta velocità la telefonia mobile e
via discorrendo
e anche questa infrastruttura si dovrà
costruire pagati partendo da quelle zone
maggiore bisogno dove maggiore è la
necessità e dovrebbe agire anche la
capacità di spesa perché anche questo è
un fattore importante
inoltre il nostro mondo si va
semplificato io sono sicuro che in sala
qualcuno che si ricorda dal pop ma
statici ancora se il venerdì sera
volevate vedere un film trovate la drop
l'asta in 30 mentre davanti alla
cassetta se lo volevate vedere come ne
prende la tv e attrazioni un anno come
fucka date lug
lo stop adesso tutti quanti voi avete
innamoramento mezzi league su sky a
quello che vi parco infiniti e non vi
fanno pagare il singolo legge che fanno
pagare il canone mensile societaria
perché vado una volta che vi hanno
collegato che vediate un film che lo
vediate
non cambia niente la stessa cosa è
accaduta nella telefonia sia fatto il
militare se ne ricorda le telefonate
alla fidanzata con il sacchetto dei
gettoni e per andare a telefonare per
sentire come stare come lo style
oggi tutti abbiamo un abbonamento sul
nostro telefono cellulare e minuti
illimitati perché costo marginale nel
minuto di conversazione talmente basso
che costa di più contabilizzarlo tanto e
fare quello penso che sia la stessa cosa
sia il mio posto tiziano è l'opposto ci
fosse una società energetica loro cosa
vorrebbero farla vorrebbero sostituire
al contatore dei litri il contatore di
kilowatt
invece io penso che andremo verso un
futuro in cui voi all'inizio nell'anima
o magari addirittura quando può parte
l'avventura più o meno stimata in numero
di chilometri che fate e pagate a tutti
i riforme
che sono necessari insomma il tema
importante il tempo è complicato ma può
essere affrontato in modo vincente
se riusciamo a vedere questa prospettiva
vincenti sono convinto che si farà
[Applauso]
[Musica]